it's a 20 million dollar project which
will shape the way houses are built and
inhabited for decades to come within a
cavernous environmental chamber at the
University of Salford two full-scale
family homes have been built
incorporating prototype materials and
bristling with energy saving technology
and devices one of the things that we
can do at energy house too that you
can't do in traditional field trials is
to take some risks so we can take
technologies that are right on the cusp
and we may not know if they're going to
work really well or not and this gives
us a chance to compare some of the
things so the the Beltway house that you
see behind me has got four different
heating systems and using those control
conditions we can compare air source
heat pump at the back air source heat
pump in the roof and the two types of
infrared heating that we've got to
really understand which one's going to
bring the biggest benefit to the
consumer inside the houses smart heating
controls which can learn and adapt
automatically to the homeowners habits
infrared heating replaces convection
radiators sensors throughout the rooms
feed data back for analysis and the
outside of the houses can be subjected
to a temperature range from a baking 40
degrees Celsius to an Arctic -20 with
optional blizzard conditions
it's a genuinely extraordinary
experience standing here in a climate
control chamber with snow falling on my
head and two full-size houses inside
behind me for the serious purpose of
this is to put technology and materials
that are going to be going into new
houses in five to ten years time and
putting them under the kind of stress
and duress that they will be facing in
15 to 100 years time as climates change
the UK's housing stock is the oldest and
least energy efficient in Europe and
more than four-fifths of those homes are
still heated by gas burning boilers we
have a digital thermometer system the
advances being tested in the energy
house are not just intended for new
build properties a lot of the technology
we'll be researching in this house will
be applicable to retrofit projects as
well so things like digital thermostats
on radiators you know central heating
systems that learn they can all be
adapted into existing properties clearly
as a new build provider we're able to
build these into the fabric of the home
but it is possible to put a lot of these
Technologies into existing homes as well
40 percent of the UK's carbon footprint
comes from the built environment
achieving Net Zero needs a step change
in the design of new buildings and the
upgrading of old but knowing what
actually works is crucial in making sure
government policy hits its targets
what's great about this project we've
got government coming here because
they're learning from our findings about
how it can inform the regulations of the
future as well because it's quite
important that the regulations are
realistic and we're able to deliver them
but also they have the right impact our
homes are usually the biggest financial
expenditure we have in our lifetimes
this groundbreaking research project
hopes to ensure that those future homes
are fit for future purpose
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera Salford